mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
ein mädchen mit brille als heldin so gab
es das denn schon
disney macht es vor mit dem
animationsfilm encanto eine der
insgesamt 23 nominationen für die
kommenden oscars
[Musik]
der unterhaltungs gigant verbindet seit
jeher kunst und kommerz und
transportiert mit seinen hauptfiguren
immer wieder große hedgefonds
[Musik]
und wir sprechen doch darüber
es kann
[Musik]
wir kommen aus dem kulturplatz ja heute
sind wir auf romantischen pfaden
unterwegs und wir machen station im
elsass nach und dafür gibt es gute
gründe
[Musik]
das elsass mit seinen schmucken
städtchen und den traditionellen
fachwerkhäusern wo offensichtlich
vorlage für die macher von disney für
ihren legendären animationsfilm beauty
and the beast die schöne und das biest
weil in ihrem heimatstädtchen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und das hier könnte der brunnen der
inspiration gewesen seien und es zu
finden im städtchen egesheim ja disney
verstand es schon immer die begeisterung
eines riesigen massenpublikums zu
entflammen und dies ziemlich konstant
seit den anfängen mit bambi oder micky
maus auch aktuell ist gigantisch nie
ganz vorne mit dabei und zwar beim
oscar-rennen vom kommenden wochenende
mit nicht weniger als 23 nominationen
[Musik]
ein disney film ohne musik das ist
komplett und denkbar kein wunder denn
der soundtrack steht ja auch für
emotionen ganz egal ob bei balu im
dschungelbuch oder bei arielle die
meerjungfrau ja und jetzt kreiert die
musik große gefühle bei encanto der
aktuelle kassenschlager
[Musik]
das ist mir aber sie lebt mit ihrer
familie in den bergen kolumbiens im dorf
bekannt
alle in ihrer familie haben magische
kräfte
außer mirabel
[Musik]
als plötzliche zuhause bedroht wird ist
jedoch die einzige die das dorf retten
kann wie es sich für diese gehört ist
doch diese geschichte handelt von vieler
bunten chance
einer dieser songs sticht besonders
heraus
[Musik]
tokio
er handelt von mir als mysteriöse monke
bruno über den man nicht sprechen darf
in kurzer zeit ist das lied zum
offiziell erfolgreichsten disney hit
aller zeiten geworden der komponist des
liedes lin manuell miranda ist dauergast
in fernsehsendung
ich wusste dass es eingängig ist denn
während ich das lied zuhause schrieb
sagen meine kinder den referrer die
ganze zeit
auch die sozialen medien sind voll mit
promo
[Musik]
was ist also das geheimnis dieses disney
songs
[Musik]
es ist ein irgendwie doch wieder
typischer disney song aus ganz vielen
verschiedenen gründen aber es ist vor
allem auch ein moderner song also die
letzten jahre hat die popmusik sich ganz
in die richtung dieser
lateinamerikanischen rhythmen orientiert
und er hat einfach wahnsinnig viel humor
drin und ich glaube dass es diese
kombination die das so spannend macht
und auch zu diesem phänomen was wir
jetzt haben britta heiligenthal ist
filmwissenschaftlerin und künstlerische
leiterin band stage theater neue flora
in hamburg
in ihrer doktorarbeit geht sie dem
geheimnis nicht songs auf den grund was
macht das ganze denn so grandios sind
vermeintliches ist ja alles ganz leicht
und einfach und auch die songs sind erst
mal nur einen gängigen so und es ist ein
wahnsinnig spannendes forschungsfeld
weil ganz vieles ebenso gut gemacht ist
dass es nur unterbewusst den zuschauer
beeinflussen
[Musik]
angefangen hat alles mit schneewittchen
und den sieben zwergen
1937 war das die geburtsstunde
des zeichentrick musicals
damals wurde die musik noch als
illustrative 's mittel eingesetzt
[Musik]
illustrierend heißt einfach alles was
ich sehe und höre mit musik zu
unterstreichen also ob das dann ist das
renn schneewittchen gibt es eine
schildkröte die rutscht die treppe
runter das wird dann mit einem
musikalischen glissando untermarkt
wenn die zwerge in der mine mit ihren
spitzhacken hacken hört man das in
metallenen percussion geräuschen
[Musik]
in den 50er und 60er jahren rücken dann
die figuren in den liedern ins zentrum
die musik dient dazu sie zu
charakterisieren
[Musik]
man nimmt balu dem bären und welche
instrumente passen dann zu einem bären
besonders gut das sind tiefe streicher
und das sind gemütliche holzbläser dann
gibt es king louie der natürlich mit
seinem new orleans jazz ganz klar
bedient werden muss in der musikalischen
stilistik die eben seinen charakter
unterstreichen
[Musik]
für den song von king louie wird sogar
eine echte jazz band ins studio besteht
die bewegungen der band werden gefilmt
damit die zeichner diese nachempfinden
können
[Musik]
verantwortlich für die meisten lieder im
dschungelbuch sind die sherman brothers
und auch bei den er ist dies nach den
beiden komponisten treue
[Musik]
wir schreiben ein lied das passen könnte
und spielen es ihnen vor dann passen die
zeichner die storyboards unserem lied an
wir wussten sofort dass unsere lieder in
französischer manier sein sollten
[Musik]
in den neunziger jahren erklingen dann
einige der größten des nissans in den
kinos
[Musik]
allesamt geschrieben vom filmkomponisten
alan menken ganze acht oscars streicht
er für die disney niederrhein bis heute
unerreicht
das allen menschen auch gemacht hat er
hat häufig diese filmhandlung auch in
den songs weitergeführt das heißt am
anfang vom song
waren wir an einem punkt die figur war
sich nicht ganz sicher welt zum beispiel
ob sie jetzt aus ihrem bekannten
territorium heraustreten sollte und ob
es da draußen noch mehr in der welt gibt
und am ende vom vom song blasius also
darin wurde die entscheidung in dem song
getroffen also auch dramaturgisch ganz
wichtige momente die da verhandelt
werden
dieses prinzip führt an elton john 1994
erfolgreich weiter
[Musik]
er komponierte könig der löwen disney
setzt nun auf bekannte größen der
popmusik
[Musik]
1999 schrieb phil collins den soundtrack
zum disney film tarzan
er singt die songs in fünf sprachen ein
inklusive auf deutsch
[Musik]
der erfolg der disney songs erreicht
2013 im film frozen einen ersten
höhepunkt
kennt
[Applaus]
ganze 2,7 milliarden mal wurde das video
zum lied let it go auf youtube bereits
angeklickt
[Musik]
7 motto lass los ermutigt jung und alt
und es zeigt wie wichtig die liedtexte
der disney songs sind da werden
grundsätzliche werte angesprochen da
geht es darum mut zu machen jedem
menschen aus dem leben zu sprechen und
das sind ganz allgemein gültige
wahrheiten die glaube ich wirklich zeit
und raum ein bisschen überdauern doch
selbst disney ist nicht unfehlbar
ausgerechnet den hits we don't talk
about bruno haben die macher im vorfeld
nicht ins rennen um einen oscar
geschickt im nachhinein ist man immer
schlauer
[Musik]
er wäre ein soundtrack liefern kann zu
einem disney streifen oder auch nur
schon für einen trailer der hat es
geschafft und unter diesen gewieften
komponisten haben wir auch einen
schweizer entdeckt
ein vorgeschmack auf die abenteuer des
astronauten buzz lightyear im juni
wörter film veröffentlicht die bilder
sind packend ebenso die musik
die meinen
das studio im keller seines wohnhauses
im waadtländischen lüthi hier arbeitet
cedrick caraballo sein amerikanischer
agent schuf den kontakt zu disney der
auftrag einen legendären sound von david
bowie neu zu arrangieren
sie bringen einen neuen film über buzz
raus und wollten einen epischen remix
des songs stammen von david bowie okay
zwei sekunden nachdenken wie es mir aber
nichts anmerken innert einer stunde habe
ich zugesagt
[Musik]
der produzent von disney ist überzeugt
mit ihm arbeitete ballo schon für den
letzten teil der star wars saga zusammen
der sound für den ersten trailer von 36
kyle walker stand ebenso in nur ein paar
tagen
[Musik]
bei dieser arbeit muss man beweisen dass
man es kann kurz durchatmen und einfach
mal sagen ich schaffe das auch wenn man
nicht ganz sicher ist ich mach das und
loslegen er hat einen steilen aufstieg
hinter sich ohne diplom schlug er sich
mit kleinen aufträgen durch konnte sich
noch vor zehn jahren keine wohnung
leisten und schlief in seinem auto
einmal im jahr übernachte ich noch in
rot auf einem öffentlichen parkplatz um
mich an meine anfänge zu erinnern
die leute sagen hast du ein glück ich
habe hart dafür gearbeitet
eigentlich steht er auf härteren sound
und schwere maschinen mit seiner großen
leidenschaft und auch etwas glück ist
vertretbar weil nun angekommen in der
traumfabrik hollywood
diesen freitag feiert sdf den schweizer
film wer hat gewonnen und was war der
emotionalste moment das alles sehen sie
in einer sondersendung ab 22 uhr auf sf
info
[Musik]
wir sind zurück im elsass und weil es
hier so schön ist und wir hier für einen
moment die erschütternde weltlage
vergessen können wir uns aufgemacht von
egis heim nach colmar hier wird sogar
romantisch war es eigentlich gar nicht
ist
[Musik]
das passt ja bestens zu den romantischen
märchen die disney so virtuos erzählt
und das genau seit 100 jahren die erste
version von rotkäppchen 1922 für
erwachsene konzipiert flimmerte in
fences missouri über die leinwand
klassische märchen stoffe dient nehmer
wieder als vorlage für viele disney
filme
auch aschenputtel cinderella im original
brachte disney in seinem witzigen und
temporeichen cartoons teil auf die
leinwand und so erfreuten sich die
zuschauer bereits damals über eine
disney prinzessin doch egal wie sehr
sich die disney prinzessinnen im laufe
der zeit veränderten etwas behielten
alle stories bei nämlich den true love
peace denkt kuss der wahren liebe
ein magischer topos im disney märchen
er kommt jeweils zum einsatz sobald die
klassische disney prinzessin rettung
nötig hat der kuss der wahren liebe
ist sie ihrem fluch erleben hat sie die
singstimme verloren oder wurde sie gar
vergiftet stets kommt ein trends und
küsst sie zurück ins leben
mit snow white legte walt disney den
ersten abendfüllenden märchenfilm vor er
entstand während vier jahren von den
inzwischen auf 750 mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern angewachsenen disney
studios per hand produziert
schneewittchen wurde ein riesenerfolg es
folgten dornröschen und cinderella mit
disney beschäftigt sich auch die
kulturwissenschaftlerin natalie bosse
sie weiß warum der unterhaltungskonzern
auf märchen setzt
spezifisch anschaut diese
eskapistische neo mediale
idyllische vorindustrielle welt ist
natürlich schon etwas sehr reizvolles
und die prinzessin in figuren die zu
symbolen für hoffnung für das gute in
den menschen werden für den sieg des
guten über das böse
das ist natürlich wahnsinnig beliebten
reizvoll das gibt hoffnung dass ist das
der perfekte weg um zum happy end zu
kommen
[Musik]
im mittelpunkt steht die prinzessin sie
ist eine naive gutherzige junge frau die
sich trotz ihres heldinnen status passiv
dafür stets tierlieb durchs leben träumt
den disney prinzessinnen also vor allem
den klassischen aus guten grund
vorgeworfen hat dass sie müssen gerettet
werden ihr einziges ziel ist die heirat
und die romantische liebe und vor allem
eine hetero romantische liebe
[Musik]
ebenfalls die immer gleiche rolle
spielen in disneys märchenverfilmungen
frauen jenseits der menopause
stiefmutter hexen böse feen verkörpern
einen matt verchen machtanspruch
hatte leider treten zu wollen sogar
sexuell selbstbewusst auf und fühlen
sich durch die prinzessinnen in ihrem
selbstverständnis gefährdet
sind wirklich möchte und ihr mächtiger
sie sind desto schlimmer ist auch ende
sie sind manipulativ sie glauben nicht
an die liebe an das gute sie lachen die
leute aus die das versuchen zu erreichen
und machen sich andere menschen zu
nutzen also sie sind wirklich ein
negativ von diesen jungen unschuldigen
prinzessinnen
aber auch disney übt sich um
selbstreflektion und ironie
2010 emanzipiert sich rapunzel küsst den
traumprinzen wann es ihr gefällt und
lässt sich die alten zöpfe abschneiden
[Musik]
zwei jahre später punkte der
tochterkonzern pixar mit prinzessin mary
da
ihre antagonistin ist wieder alte hexe
noch selbstverliebte stiefmutter
stattdessen ist es die leibliche mutter
die mit der kratzbürstig kite der
tochter zu kämpfen hat
2014 doppelt disney mit einer
computeranimierten realverfilmung von
dornröschen auch
wen haben wir denn da
die titelgebende hauptfigur ist
allerdings keine prinzessin mir sondern
die fehmer wissend die dornröschen
verwünscht schnell bemerkt das publikum
das die geschichte vielleicht ganz
anders war als bisher geglaubt
da hat es sind eine
hintergrundgeschichte bekommen wo
gezeigt wird wie sie überhaupt zu dieser
defensiven rachesüchtigen viel geworden
ist und der grund dafür ist ja ein sehr
tragischen nämlich date rape
beim romantischen treffen mit der fee
mehlis sind flößt ihr prinz stefan k -o
-tropfen ein der viel passiert was sonst
den prinzessinnen widerfährt nur ist es
der prinz selbst der das verbrechen
verübt um elf cent die flügel raubt um
könig zu werden
da sieht man dass sich dieses schwarz
weiß denken bei diesen figuren durchaus
auch aufgelöst hat bis zu einem gewissen
grad
disneys prinzessinnen
emanzipieren sich also schlagen böse
prinzen ko die ferien sind im grunde
ihres herzens gut und sogar der kurs der
wahren liebe ist nicht mehr was er in
den anfängen des mies war er verlässt
die romantische ebene und verschiebt
sich zugunsten anderer beziehungsformen
um wieder auf das beispiel
zurückzukommen da kommt dieser kuss ja
auch vor und da ist es die böse fee die
quasi ihren eigenen fu
aufhebt indem sie
küsst
[Musik]
der kurs wurde auch in nicht romantische
formen umgewandelt das sind umarmungen
von geschwistern oder von tochter und
mutter die es geschafft haben ihr
zerwürfnis zu überwinden
[Musik]
aber ist dieser wandel progressiv oder
hängt disney gesellschaftlichen
entwicklungen hinterher
es geht um macht es geht um absatzzahlen
dass die publikumszahlen disney
produziert diese filme nicht aus
herzensgüte und um die gesellschaft zu
erziehen sie möchten geld machen
inzwischen hat sich ein eigener disney
kosmos auch innerhalb der märchenwelt
etabliert der durchaus ironie und
parodie verträgt mit viel sinn für
familien unterhaltung und natürlich für
das große geschäft
[Musik]
wer wissen will wie viele oscars disney
ab und schaue sich am wochenende die
oscar verleihung wir fragen nächste
woche ob wir mit dem krieg in der
ukraine an einer grundlegenden
zeitenwende stehen und gleich als folgt
ihr auf sf1 der kurzfilm taken tron der
schweizer anwärter unter den kurzfilmen
ist in der kategorie live action short
nominiert ich wünsche ihnen eine gute
woche euro ab
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]